اذا حرق دولي مكثف سيما من حلفاء اكياز
لمساعداتها في تدارك النقص والازمه في
مجال الطاقه سواء عبر دعمها بالغاز
والكهرباء او مساعدتها في النهوض مجددا
عبر اصلاح منشاتها التي دمرها القصفه
الروسيه بدورها تبذل اوكرانيا جهودا حثيثه
لاستعاده التيار الكهربائي بشكل كامل بعد
نحو اسبوع من موجب ضربات صاروخيه روسيه
الحقت اضرار جسيما بمنشات للطاقه في انحاء
البلاد ومع استمرار ضربات الروسيه على
البنا التحتيه في اوكرانيا
اعلنتاز ان القصر الروسي استهدف البنيه
التحتيه في مقاطعه نيبرو جنوبيه البلاد من
الطاقه الى مصادر مياه الشرب بدات موسكو
توسع اهدافها داخل اوكرانيا اذا ان
الضربات استهدفت ايضا مضخات المياه في
ميكولاج التي تتم عبر او تمر عبره
وعلى ذكر خير اعلنا الحاكم الاقليمي
للمدينه انهم استطاعوا حتى الان تامين فقط
17% من الكهرباء للمشتركين مشددين على ان
اعاده التيار لباك باقي المناطق سيتم
قريبا بشرط عدم استهداف المزيد من البنيه
التحتيه من قبل روسيا قبل ذلك انذر الرئيس
الاوكراني نيفلودي ميرسيلين سكي مواطنيه
باسبوع اخر من الظلام والبرد متوقعا مزيد
من الضربه الروسيه المتراكزه على منشات
الطاقه في البلاد وقال ذيلنسكي ان رد
موسكو على فشلها الكبير على ارض المعركه
سيكون بالحق المزيد من الدمار بالبنيه
التحتيه لاوكرانيا مشددا على ان موسكو
ستقصف بلاده حتى نفاذ صواريخها من جهته
شدد وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني دي
متروكوليبا على ان بلاده بحاجه ملحها الى
محولات كهربائيه فضلا عن دفاعات جويه
محسنه لصد الضربات الجويه الروسيه على
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
[موسيقى]